on l'a vu sur la pendule il est 10
heures normalement les personnes danger
dès 8 heures le repas est servi à 18h
vous regardez l'italie personne de ben
ali les assiettes les gens sont assis
devant leur assiette mais
personnellement pour faire manger ces
gens il faut de l'assistance il faut une
aide soignante il faut viser deux
soignantes l'idéal ce serait une
aide-soignante par table gens ne savent
pas manger seule la le monsieur état
civil un de son plein il son dessert il
a même pas commencé à manger le plat
pour la simple raison qu'il ne sait pas
en danger lui c'est pareil voilà
personne ne mange est il là il faut il
faut du personnel pour les aider quoi
voilà c'était insoutenable un des
extraits sirigu alors et la caisse où
vous avez souhaité dénoncer mais ce
qu'on a pu voir dans ces images
d'ailleurs je les ai pas revus depuis je
me sens très ému de revoir ces images
mais parce que c'est la réalité parce
que ça se passe encore et parce que
aujourd'hui nos aînés sont maltraités
dans les ehpad en france ouais
c'est à dire on leur fait quoi mais on
les aide pas on n'est pas là pour eux on
les abandonne on a l'impression non en
tant que soignant alors que c'est leur
vocation et c'est un métier qu'on a
choisi par vocation et des maltraitances
oui à des maltraitances quel jour pas
des maltraitances physiques parce qu'on
n'est pas là pour frapper nos résidents
on n'est pas là pour ça mais à des
maltraitance institutionnelle quand vous
avez une direction qui vous impose
d'utiliser simplement trois couches par
jour et que vous avez des résidents mais
finalement je vais pas trois fois aux
toilettes dans la journée ça m'arrive
d'aller plus souvent mais si j'ai une
couche et que j'ai aux toilettes et
qu'on me dit on remet la ta couche parce
que
parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre je me vois
pas remettre une couche salle mais je
pense que personne ici ce revers et
mettre une couche salle quand vous avez
des résidents qui ont les repas avait
son service super toi on a pu le voir là
c'est 18 heures quand depuis déjà 18
heures vous avez plus rien dans le
ventre jusqu'au lendemain matin était
déjà 18 heures on vous a pas servi à
grand chose le lendemain matin on vous
dit ab ce matin vous aurez qu'une
boisson parce qu'on a plus de madeleine
et quand on se sera un verre d'eau parce
que la plus de jus de fruits
quand vous payez plus de 5000 euros que
vous avez travaillé toute votre vie et
que vous arrivez à la fin de votre vie
vous avez envie juste de partir
paisiblement et d'apprécier les derniers
jours qui vous reste quand on vous fait
subir ça mais ça c'est de la
maltraitance alors il ya le journaliste
victor castanet au tour d'une hauteur
d'une île et fossoyeurs qui dénonce les
maltraitances en ehpad il était l'invité
de bfm tv et regardez il racontait qu'il
avait subi des pressions on lui aurait
même proposé des millions d'euros pour
arrêter son enquête regarder ça a été
une enquête longue difficile parce
qu'effectivement
j'ai reçu un certain nombre de pressions
et de menaces de la part du groupe mais
aussi les gens qui ont participé à cette
enquête j'ai eu des sources qui
effectivement me rencontrer pendant
quatre rendez vous très long m'ont donné
des documents et qui du jour au
lendemain après avoir été contacté par
le groupe faisait machine arrière et
effectivement il est arrivé à la moitié
de mon enquête pas directement par le
groupe mais via un intermédiaire qui m'a
fait effectivement une proposition me
demandant si je serai prêt à arrêter
cette enquête pour pour 15 millions
d'euros 1 oui j le savoir que c'est un
système qui draine des milliards d'euros
le groupe auquel il s'est attaqué c'est
le numéro un mondial est donc pour eux
15 millions c'est une somme énorme mais
pour eux c'est rien dès que le livre est
sorti l'action en bourse a tellement
davis et que la cotation était
interrompue pour eux c'est une
catastrophe est ce un scandale national
cyril ce un scandale national parce que
nos personnes âgées sont installés pour
des sommes folles dans des mouroirs
alors ce sont des mots vides et un
faussement moi j'en connais je sais que
il ya plein d' espace où les gens sont
démunis on les a privés d'accès
notamment pendant la pandémie n'ont pas
pu aller voir entre guillemets leurs
vieux je le dis avec amour et respect
qui ont été traités et c'est vrai que il
ya l'hygiène a encore diminué la
nourriture a encore diminué parce qu'ils
avaient plus de contrôles pendant la
pandémie j'ai hâte de savoir comment
monsieur va réagir parce que c'est un
scandale national le patron d'orpea va
être reçus par la ministre un
bourguignon en charge du dossier mais
c'est très grave ce qui se passe je suis
bouleversé par ce qu'on espère surtout
gilles que ce monsieur ne va pas
maintien qui va arrêter de dire des
conneries qu'il n'est pas venu ici pour
dire des conneries et mentir à toute la
france parce qu'il s'agit de nos aînés
de nos parents de nous mêmes plus tard
et arrêter de mentir ans et je sais pas
ce que vous allez dire mais peu importe
la connerie que vous allez sortir soyez
francs battant alors ben justement
danny foster directeur d'un ehpad
bonjour mais est ce que vous avez à dire
d'abord moi j'étais de soignants avant
c'est très bien vous avez fini directeur
c'est pas pour rien parce que vous aviez
mal lorsque vous faisiez monsieur et que
vous avez trouvé une issue de secours
c'est parce qu'elle trouve être passé
mais c'est très bien pour vous très bien
bon en tout cas évidemment il ya des
certains répètent qu'ils marchent et
d'autres qui ne marche pas il faut l'y
donc dénoncé comme vous l'avez très bien
fait mais dénoncée après avoir été
licencié je trouve ça un peu purement
scandaleux si vous avez alors on voit la
région parce que j'ai jeunes ont mais
renvoie nouveau source parce que j'ai
pas des lancers après avoir été licencié
ce dîner offert d'être aussi lorsque
j'ai été licencié a dénoncé lundi des
conneries vous êtes après déjà des
conneries monsieur non mais si vous êtes
vous êtes après deux tirs des cobras
anjou qui en est excusez moi tout 606
connaissions non je ne connais pas mais
c'est un gros combat à partir du moment
où il dit des conneries comme ça ça me
ronge et quand vous desservez oui c'est
vrai je trouve que vous avez alors
difficile et s'est arrêté la même façon
vos résidents comme ça oui ils sont
maltraités ouais je veux dire la même
chose vous messieurs mais non alors non
mais qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça
bah oui évidemment c'est évidemment
choquant en tout cas dans notre
résidence pas du tout le cas
les soignons accès libre évidemment
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même une chaîne
télévision est venue dans les pattes
pour filmer et évidemment qu'on doit
justement dans une maltraitance ou pas
il ya des vallées de l'histoire des
trois couches par jour est ce que c'est
possible je leur annonce est totalement
faux enfin ils ont accès à aucun des
deux matches de france je ne peux pas
dire tantôt les épaves ne fréquente pas
dans tous les états mais j'étais de
soignants quand même dans la région paca
j'ai cédé j'étais intérimaire et j'ai
jamais vu cela enfin on avait accès aux
protections peut-être dans certains
ehpad la qualité de la protection était
différente à d'autres ça je suis prêt à
le reconnaître mais ça a bien changé
depuis au moins 2013 et je pense qu'il
faut peut être regarder vers l'avenir
qu'est ce qu'on peut apporter comme
solution et je pense que oui durant la
crise sanitaire c'était extrêmement
choquant de voir des personnes confinées
j'ai malheureusement vite qu un cluster
la rs pas demandé de confiner les
personnes âgées et pour certains
malheureusement nous avons perdu parce
qu'ils sont des cds liés aux covin mais
à cause d'un syndrome dépressif et non
pas moi non sa chute chaud je suis tout
à fait d'accord de le reconnaître mais
ce sont des consignes imposées par le
gouvernement par contre ce que vous
faites vous sans arrêt toujours faire de
l'ehpad bas chine en dix ans il n'y a
pas su s'il n'y a pas si vous l'avez
cautionner du coup et vous les avez vu
les images mais je savais je suis pas la
seule à avoir des lancers vous savez
lorsque bon là c'est oui certes c'est
choquant mais ce que peut-être je sais
pas n'est pas une situation où il ya une
situation plus grave et du coup les
aides soignants était peut-être en train
de jeu sait pas s'occuper de la ville
avait donc je reviens pour résident pas
résidents moi j'en ai combien alors 58
résidents nous avons à peu près 10
personnels voile d'accord ça fait comme
une résidents parts soignants 5,6
d'accord mais alors votre et pas des
modèles en france on ne renie pas mais
j'avais vraiment vous savez comment cela
votre avait vraiment dit cela va être la
mienne moi j'étais secrétaire savez quoi
je prie
juste la réalité préférions soignants
pour qu'ils résident alors vous savez
compter vous êtes directeur parce que
l'on aimait bien les comptes ça fait
comment des minutes par résident 3
minutes 75e monsieur vous arrivez vous à
laver quelqu'un 3075 ça ce nombre près
pad peut-être dans votre esprit est là
décembre dit j'espère deviner qu est ce
que vous avez lu mais qu'est ce que
j'avais fait à part dénoncé dans la
presse vous voulez que je fasse quoi
monsieur je suis un petit apprenant
qu'ils gagnent les landes